today we're talking about Security
customer success and a one-click
training model I'm Daryl and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news don't forget to
check out our monthly post from the
cyber security action team in the
October Edition we went over the Google
Cloud next conference and mandian's
inaugural mwise conference
these announcements will reveal how we
are approaching the thorniest cyber
security challenges facing the industry
today learn more on the blog on our blog
learn more about how Google has invested
in our customer experience team and the
organized resources to be closer to our
customers while providing more valuable
interactions and partnership
it's not an accident that Google cloud
is easier to partner with and this post
details the how and why along with the
impact of such strategies for our users
we introduced document AI so users can
extract structured data from documents
through ml models to automate business
processes and improve decision making
the recent release of document AI
workbench lets analysts developers and
even business users quickly and easily
apply ml to virtually any document-based
workflow
relative to traditional development
approaches document AI workbench lets
organizations build models faster and
with less data accelerating time to
value for processing and Analysis of
unstructured data in documents learn
more on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud